Speaker 1: . One of the big things that happened
during our vacation is that the Trump organization,
meaning Trump's business and its CFO, Alan
Weisberg, were indicted on multiple criminal
charges, 15 felony counts against Alan Weisberg.
Now, this is significant.
The charges are serious.
They involve tax fraud of various kinds, including
failing to report and pay taxes on a bunch
of different benefits cars, apartments, school
tuition.
It includes state and federal income tax fraud,
state and local tax fraud.
More generally, the reaction from the right
and from Trump's family, exactly as everybody
who's been paying attention predicted has
been, this is bogus, politically motivated
nonsense.
But of course, because they can't seem to
resist Trump's children, Don Jr. and Eric
Trump went on TV and basically admitted they
did all the stuff they admit to it in the
context of saying this is small potatoes.
They admit to it in the context of saying
we're only being targeted for this for political
reasons.
But they admit to it much like Trump did at
his rally in Florida over the weekend.
They both Don Jr. and Eric had complete meltdowns.
In this first clip, we're going to look at
a Newsmax host, Eric Bolling, asking Eric
whether he thinks he or his siblings might
be indicted.
And Eric just loses his mind and starts talking
about Hunter Biden, if you can believe it.
Let's take a look at this here, Eric.
Speaker 2: Are you concerned that they may
send an indictment your way, your brother's
way or your sister's way?
You know what?
I'm not, Eric, because guess what?
We've always lived amazingly clean lives.
And believe me, if they could have they already
what if.
Right.
Speaker 1: There is no way that this was going
on 15 years at the Trump Organization and
none of the Trump's knew nothing happens at
the Trump organization without Trump or one
of his kids knowing it.
It's just not plausible.
Speaker 2: I mean, that's what they wanted.
That was their end goal.
You know, the difference is I'm not a hunter,
Biden.
I'm not selling paintings to undisclosed people
for half a million dollars apiece.
I'm not doing, you know, draw.
Speaker 1: There's no reason to believe there's
anything criminal in what Hunter Biden is
doing with his paintings.
Speaker 2: I'll be seen in shady hotels.
I'm not I'm not going out and soliciting prostitution
and I'm not going out and selling influence
the Ukraine and China and having lavish trips
paid for a while.
You know,
Speaker 1: those things can all be investigated,
but it's not the subject of this interview.
Speaker 2: Others commander in chief.
No, I'm not doing that.
You know what we do, Don Ivonka.
And I really, really, you know, nice, clean
lives.
And we work very, very hard.
And guess what?
Long before politics ever came into our lives,
we were in the business world and we were
successful and we worked very hard.
And we live clean lives is very different
than the Bidens.
And we're never in business until their father
actually got into politics.
And and they've built it for everything it's
worth.
And they still do it to this day.
And you know, Eric, where is the D.A. there,
you know, when you have text messages of prostitutes,
so
Speaker 1: much of what he's talking, you
know, the D.A., a lot of that stuff is in
different jurisdictions.
They're allegations, many of which have been
looked into and found to be completely baseless,
just melting down completely.
Now, in this next clip from Fox News, Eric
Trump admits these are employment perks.
Everything that's alleged is true, but it
simply shouldn't be a criminal matter.
He's saying, you know, Eric, you don't have
to do these interviews.
I don't think he knows that.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, these are employment
perks, these are you know, these are, you
know, a corporate car, which everybody has.
I guarantee you, there's people
Speaker 1: who doesn't have a corporate car.
Guys, come on.
Speaker 2: Well, on this network that out
of corporate cars, I guarantee you there's
people in every company in the country that
have corporate vehicles.
This is what they're going after.
This isn't a criminal matter.
This is you know, it's really interesting,
Raymond, after the financial crisis.
Right.
Speaker 1: So you see what he did there.
He admitted, admitted to all of it.
But he says this just isn't a criminal matter
or what he means is it shouldn't be.
That's his opinion.
But he's admitting to the stuff.
That's what's amazing.
Speaker 2: Every single person on Wall Street,
despite the fact that these people were literally
they took down the US economy.
But they'll go down.
They'll go after somebody after fringe employment
benefits.
Is that really what the DEA is focused on
as little girls are getting shot in the middle
of Times Square, they'll go after a corporate
vehicle and a corporate apartment.
Speaker 1: Give me understand that there's
not a single denial here.
He's admitting all of it.
He's just saying they shouldn't be focused
on this break.
Speaker 2: And honestly, I have to say, the
media has actually been very fair about this.
And The New York Times, so many of the different
news outlets, they've literally said this
isn't this isn't criminal.
This isn't worth well for investigators.
And it would only be this would normally be
a civil complaint.
Speaker 1: OK, so there there is that.
And then Don Jr. on Fox News with Dan Bongino
also admitting all of it.
But just saying this shouldn't be the focus
of the criminal system.
Speaker 2: They dressed up the indictment.
Obviously, they dress it up.
They make it look really serious.
They say he didn't pay taxes on one point
seven million dollars worth of stuff over
16 years.
So that's to New York State, eight percent
of that.
One hundred and thirty six thousand dollars.
Half of that was because my father paid for
his grandchildren's school in New York City.
Speaker 1: Did you?
So that's one of the allegations that Donald
Trump just directly paid Alan Weisberg's kids
tuition.
That has to be taxed.
If I have a business lease, the amount that
my business pays for my car lease, I'm I have
to pay taxes on that.
That is a benefit.
And that's a lot less money than what we're
talking about here for tuition.
Don is basically saying it was over a long
period of time and it's not that much money
per month, but he's admitting it all.
Speaker 2: So you take that out.
It amounts to about five grand a month.
Oh, no, because what they promised, they brought
in outside prosecutors.
They teamed up with the attorney general of
New York State to do this.
Speaker 1: So while so there it is not denying
any of it.
Their strategy is admit it all in plain sight,
but say it shouldn't be criminal.
And there's prosecutorial discretion that's
being applied in a politically biased way.
Do they know they don't have to do these interviews
and that they don't have to say these things?
Or is this genuinely the only way they can
think of to defend themselves, to say, yeah,
I mean, we kind of did it all, but none of
it should be illegal, or at least it should
be a civil issue, or at least they should
go after somebody else.
Disastrous.
And they've essentially over the weekend,
Don Junior, Eric and Donald Trump himself
at his rally in Sarasota, they admitted to
all of it, but they're saying it just really
isn't that serious.
Unbelievable.
And we'll see if that defense works out for
them.
It actually may.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this